- "Do not drink as a shot
under any circumstances."
What kind of idiot would shot this anyway?
- (bleep) it.
Let's do a shot.
(dramatic instrumental music)
- But this could go really badly.
- I'm scared I'm gonna shit my pants.
- It's that bottle,
it's (bleep) terrifying.
- Photo of what looks like a devil.
- Tiny but threatening.
- This is gonna be like
a really good date.
I'll get drunk
and then tomorrow I'll have a headache
and a burning arsehole.
- I'm Asian, I can totally do this.
Bring it on.
- Bottoms up.
- Ho!
Oh!
- Oh my God.
- Oh (bleep).
Oh (bleep).
- Holy shit.
- What the actual (bleep)?
- I no longer have a tongue.
(coughing)
(gagging)
- My mouth is on fire.
My stomach is on fire.
- I feel really light headed right now.
- Woo!
- I think my heart's even
beating a little bit faster.
- That's rude.
That's (bleep).
- I feel stoned.
- I feel like I'm pissing my pants
but I know that I'm not.
- It feels like I've eaten chili
and then washed it out with
the world's hottest chili.
- My tongue feels like the
looks like this guy right now.
This beer's doing nothing.
- That is for sure the spiciest thing
that I've ever had in my mouth.
- I feel as though I've had
six vodka shots in a row.
- My toilet come tomorrow morning,
is going to be a (bleep) nightmare.
- I'm an idiot
and I don't learn from my mistakes.
So (bleep) yeah I would do that again.
- I don't even understand
why people would drink that.
Like, why is that enjoyable?
- What I want to do now is
play a game with my friends
on who can do the most shots of this.
I might lose a friend to death.
- I would like to go home now please.
This (bleep) sucked.
- This wasn't made for humans.
Only demons.
(instrumental music)